off yeah and they're going here we go
second blitz game what are we seeing
second blitz game and mamajorov is
trying to basically copy what he did two
games ago when he managed to get that
key win in the rapid portion
van ferris has gone for something
different and actually there's been a
quick of pawns a quick trade of knights
early on this is a variation of what we
call the grunfeld defense that's been a
theme of today actually um it's the
fiance variation if you look at white's
light square bishop black's light
squared bishop they're both parked on
really long diagonals that being said
black is supposed to be doing quite okay
in this variation i've played it my
whole career with white and with black
this night move and uh okay we will see
a trade of pawns in the center now
most likely black's king can also castle
this has a very drawish reputation i've
got to say this opening this variation
at least
until this last move my manager of
pushing a pawn forward and sacrificing
jordan
you saw the reaction on his face there
allowing this move is not supposed to be
ideal for black
so maybe maybe he has thrown a little
bit i mean like this is an ideal move
for white to play if white can get away
of it because you you gain space in the
center that you can build an attack
around so uh um yeah i just feel
jordan's a bit thrown at the moment yeah
he doesn't look comfortable you're okay
we did see a trade of uh knights there
as well so no more night forks no more
night checks all of the knights have
left the board um actually in blitz
that's really useful um you don't want
to walk into any nightfalks knights are
so tricky to handle in short time
controls that being said white has extra
space in the position white's pawn in
the center of the board far more
advanced than any of black's pawns and
why it has that extra central pawn
white's going to throw everything
forward kai middle it's kind of a mama
jar of i say mama java position we just
seen him grind down a beautiful
positional game but he really is in his
element when he's coming forwards
towards his opponent's king and at some
point you can see the pawns near white's
king can just move forwards
and start steamrolling up the board you
know space invading
yeah
you have to make that sound happen more
later
it sounded like the countdown theme
he's just stopped now he's frozen for 30
seconds more than 30 seconds he's
nearly two minutes down on the clock
already jordan because he's scared of
the white pawns in the center just
marching forward
that's where white has the poor majority
black is stuck for a plan the evaluation
bar already hating black's position wow
yeah i have to say i really despise
black's position as well because you
know like you guys said you know white
has free hand in just pushing those
pawns in the center also i you know
there's not that much things that black
can do to challenge this pawns and
lastly i think it's going to be so easy
for white to trade off dark square
bishops and make
the right side extra vulnerable he just
needs to move he's been thinking for
over a minute on one move and it's not
even a critical position there's no
threat in the position there's nothing
he needs to react to nothing he needs to
calculate he's just frozen okay he hates
his position but you need to move i
think he can see what's coming isn't he
and that's the problem he just can't
find a plan i mean whatever you play you
can make your position worse even if you
move the e pawn i mean we could show
that maybe just highlight it very
quickly but let's say black tries to do
something against the center by moving
the e pawn okay he's done something else
but we can show this well white can at
least move the c pawn and if you have an
exchange in the center of board you've
given your opponent a past pawn so you
know whatever you do it could just get
worse so he's gone for something drastic
and i can totally understand why he's
done this just to show this is white's
plan pushing all the pawns forward in
the center later we're going to see
something very similar jordan tried to
chip away at the pawns from the side but
i think shaq might just ignore this and
start pushing his own pawns at some
point you can maybe just get greedy and
take a pawn
it's a matter of taste here for shaq but
we will see he can take a pawn here and
maybe just get greedy with the white
rook this is a porn advantage he can put
that in the bank for later or he can
just stay consistent and start pushing i
have to say that i like what jordan's
done there at least he's unbalancing a
very bad position and shaq has has
grabbed that pawn but you know jordan's
got a passport himself now so worth
doing this i feel yeah i think it is a
good uh roll of the dice from jordan
because like you say you know activated
his pieces
therefore
you know this actually makes life much
more difficult for shakira because he
has to handle his opponent's activity i
personally would never have taken that
let's forget about general terms though
because yes white's a pawn up but this
is the move instantly i would play in
blitz without thinking i think he's too
simon yeah he's played it he's given up
a rook for this powerful black bishop
look at the black bishop on this
diagonal he's given it up but now look
at the black king so many holes around
it once the white bishop comes to this
square the white queen is also going to
jump in with checkmate this looks
terrible for jordan i'm surprised the
computer's not enthused at all by
white's decision but to me in human
terms it looks great for white i think
black's got to try to get the queens off
here i mean if you don't get the queens
off you're probably going to get
checkmated so can you get away by yeah
playing this move david um and trying to
chase the queen wherever it goes
basically because at least you've got
the rook behind it swap the queens off
try to get some defense going this is i
mean i don't know if this works as you
might be capture push the pawn in the
center um at some point but uh this
looks like the keep the queens on maybe
keep the queens on go for an attack um
just to point out so black here does
have a rook for white's bishop and two
pawns so it's that oh my gosh
no
what's happened here
he's taken he's taking the pawn i mean
it has to be a blunder because the
bishop will just come out gift and
thread and checkmate once the pawn moves
i mean there's like so many
things that kind of appeal like pushing
the pawn forward black had to block this
and as you guys mentioned very minimum
you can take this rook and white has one
pawn for free but also you could think
about pushing this pawn forward
threatening a check hitting the king
hitting the rook this one looks game
over you could maybe move the queen
forward first hitting the rook i like
that move david's attacking the rook
getting ready to push pawn
everything seems hot jordan's gonna be
kicking himself if he loses this one
shaq's got enough he's got four minutes
as well so he did this before take a
little bit of time just to try and work
out what the best move is um
horrible opening for uh for jordan so he
was thrown this move also looks logical
maybe it wasn't as good as uh actually
attacking the rook but it was
very beautiful so who can resist that i
mean there might be some drawing chances
here because there's not many pawns left
right if there's another exchange of
pawns you know it's uh you get to an
ending you can draw that one yeah you're
right there suddenly it's much less
clear i think he had a clear win shaq
and also he had two extra minutes on the
clock but he didn't stop so both players
struggling with the pace of the game
shakur are still one point up big big
favorite now but jordan pieces are poor
and pawns are getting traded
disappearing he's got some drawing
chances yeah he needs a miracle just
like the miracle shaq pulled in the last
game ah
all right well
if he wins this shakur will gain two
points and will be on the same score but
uh winning this match will be uh
in front of juden on the standings in
the tournament and yesterday jordan won
against magnus maybe losing the match
against chocolatier today and tomorrow
shakira will play magnus carlsen
everyone's winning against everyone here
everyone's really strong yeah
that's the thing and actually i i kind
of like what jordan's done i mean he's
got a defensive setup
he's gonna have to defend for a long
time but he's suddenly got some solid
feeling to his position um i know it's a
pawn down i know it's a bit horrible but
you know you're defending everything so
it's not as bad as it was that's for
sure yeah if the queen's come off you
really fancy black's chances to draw
this game um the one downside for black
is that the black king is still a bit
airy a bit loose open there and uh okay
just a few more moves but i think that's
what jordan shared for a queen trait i
think white wants to keep the queens on
the board to attack later
and uh okay meanwhile no progress and
also the change of momentum
white's still dominant but no direct
attack it's all about a slow build up
now that could be in black's favor and i
do
i have to say i do like shaq's last move
you know just advancing the bishop by
one square
bringing advancing the king one square
no it's it's nice to bring the pieces
slowly forward and uh islamic steady
does win the race in these types of
positions
yeah i mean jordan's got a good
defensive position now he's brought his
bishop back to cover anything around his
king so it's just whether shaq can break
through and i think at some point shaq
will have to take a little bit of risk
by advancing a porn
to to break through but um i you know so
it's it's not it's not easy to break
this down yeah shaq i just don't
understand why he rushed earlier he
still got three minutes on the clock
surely his instincts would have been
tingling he must have known he was
winning on the spot but he uh he paused
and he's gone into this position which
is very different now it's uh it's all
about whether actually black can hold a
fortress and look at black's pieces the
rook bishop and king just huddled
together he's just curling up into a
ball now jordan and he's saying okay you
can't break me there's no holes in my
armor but
it feels like a song i'm going to go
draw i'm going to i think he's going to
hold this one yeah i hear him again
um yeah we haven't seen it yet why not
let's see it you know and i think
jordan's looking a bit more confident
now he probably realizes he was losing
he's got a bit of momentum on his side
now i don't know i'm going to go win
you're going to go in yeah yeah david
[Laughter]
i'll go i think white will win
eventually it's just too difficult to
defend and also i'm looking at clock
times black is not only defending but
two minutes down on the clock as well
and all the experience that chakriar has
he must have been in thai breaks before
many many many
um jordan meanwhile he's
kind of uh he's played bits his whole
career he's young he's been playing
online his whole life so
he's got some experience too
okay the black queen ooh sneaky throw
out the black queen threatening to come
down diagonally and take one of the
white pawns and uh okay that's been
defended by white's rook going backwards
though no progress suddenly i'm more on
simon's side suddenly i think maybe a
draw it's not gone well for shaq in the
last few moves yeah
no i mean uh he he hasn't proved
anything yet he's got to break things
open i don't think he's going to be able
to do this just with his pieces i mean
let's look at the time as well the time
is actually against jordan jordan's down
to a minute shaq two and a half i think
if shaq gets shorter time this will be
uh you know he could it could actually
even go wrong because he's uh i don't
think he's as david said as quick with a
mouse as jordan us and also with queens
and rooks on the board and clocks
ticking that must be difficult yeah and
that's why jordan actually he's really
sneaky he's forced a rook trade there he
got the rooks off the board and the
queen's
this must be a draw a technical draw
even now i don't know
bishop endings are very complicated four
versus three i think if black's pawns if
you look at black's pawns two of them
are on white squares if all of black's
pawns are on dark squares it will be a
dead draw no chance but because two of
black's pawns are on light squares they
are targets for white's bishop so
has this has this helped uh jordan
though by swapping pieces you'd assume
the more pieces that get off the nearer
you are but you're right those poor
those pawns are horribly on light
squares if if white can get around to
attack them and you can never exchange
bishops when you're black here if you
ever exchange bishops off the board it's
a losing king and pawn ending yeah and
now you can see white king advancing up
to the fourth row
that's already one little step
and now that's all that's needed is to
kind of
push the black bishop off this diagonal
but i mean it's still very tricky i
think it's going to be close to a i mean
that word keeps coming up fortress right
can black just sit and do nothing and
what is white's plan if black does that
does white have a winning breakthrough
maybe white has to exchange another pawn
somehow to try and break through but
then you're getting closer and closer to
the draw uh and he he's probably now
threatening to well not threatening but
aiming to push the pawn in the middle of
the board uh and maybe he has to do this
at some point
and one thing that
okay he has he's trying to make the
breakthrough now he's using the white
bishop to attack some of black's pawns
those black pawns on light squares are
vulnerable jordan needs to defend it
with his bishop passive
but one thing as well that top ground
masters always look at when they have
bishop end games they look at the colour
of the corner square and if you look on
the right half of the board harry the h
pawn on the h8 square at the top of the
board that is a dark square so white's
bishop is on a light square so actually
if white is and if white ends up even if
he wins everything that black has if
white ends up with a light squared
bishop and that h pawn it's still not
enough it promotes on the wrong color
square i think it's a dead draw i think
there you go i'm going to say it yeah
just sit here and just wait and uh
that's what's going to happen armageddon
midnight comes and
oh this last move is a bit strange by
black bringing the king forward the
black king surely has to go back now
hide on the dart squares yeah i think
the problem for white is like you say
simon maybe it's just a draw the white
king can't snake the whole way around
black's king will just block off the way
there's a threat though david bishop d3
now uh swapping the bishops i'll say we
can maybe show this the king goes back
very quickly on the analysis board uh
we've mentioned that if white can swap
the bishops off then it could be losing
so this is this is this is why he had to
move the bishop there uh just to avoid
the exchange of bishops so just to show
yeah if the bishops come off then white
is winning white has an extra pawn
meanwhile now the white king is coming
yeah this is huge the king is now on the
fifth row it's gonna come in
the white king is coming and you're
gonna have to give up another pawn he's
two pawns down suddenly he's hopeless
looks like a dead draw now doesn't it
well definitely the clocks and look he's
making moves with one second on the
clock all white needs to do now is bring
his bishop back bring his king back and
challenge black's bishop if he can trade
off the bishops um there's a lot of
moves there but if he can trade off
these guys it's just a win it's still
completely winning now for white uh yeah
two seconds
we're not gonna see him and uh okay now
now he's doing it yeah yeah he's as
mentioned he's just bringing the white
bishop back force the black bishop to a
bad square now the white king will
reactivate itself forward at the right
time you can create a second past pawn
potentially there's probably a couple of
ways to win this actually and now i mean
you have to be a little bit careful you
don't want to rush it by i was going to
say playing this move so i'm glad i'm
glad i'm getting things right
this is the key right black if black can
give up the bishop for white's central
pawn and hide the black king in the
corner on the h8 square it's still a
draw so some small chances the problem
is you will never see shaq push forward
the central pawn and let the black
bishop give itself up
this one now yeah it's just winning the
black king is forced into the corner and
white will push the central pawn after
he's kicked away black's bishop
but hang on a second you know the bishop
can start moving around the
it can redirect itself to another
diagonal
yeah
i think this one is winning you know
i'm not even going to say anymore
i i think it should be winning but it's
not so simple funnily enough there are
stalemate ideas all the time with
black's king in the corner when you're
defending put your king in the corner
at all levels just in case your opponent
is stable oh this one was a killer
lovely tactic
and a hundred on the bar and a lost a
handshake between the two fighters and a
big smile from chakria and momodaro he
wins